[موسيقى]
انا ناجيه من سرطان الثدي وتشخص قبل وجودي
وقبل عملي مع البرنامج الاردني للسرطان
الثاني انا بعتبر حالي محظوظه انه مسيرتي
ورحلتي هي اللي قادتني للمكان اللي انا
فيه هون يعني سواء رحلتي الشخصيه والعمليه
قصتي ورحلتي يعني كان دافع لي وشكلت
التزام قوي عندي باني اوعي بسرطان الثدي
هذا السرطان اللي بامكاننا انه نسيطر عليه
بالكشف المبكر
معركتنا ضد هذا المرض هي معركه وعي صار
عندي التجربه تجربه المريض تجربه الشخص
اللي مر بهذا الشيء فصار في عندي القدره
على التمييز ما بين الانشطه والمبادرات
اللي ممكن تاثر تاثير مباشر على حياه
السيدات احنا دائما لما نحكي عن سرطان
الثدي بنشد على الكشف المبكر لان الكشف
المبكر هو الاساس في السيطره على المرض
وفي ضمان نتائج يعني صحيه ومخرجات صحيه
ومعدلات شفاء ونجاه مرتفعه يعني تصل لل
95% واكثر حتى لما يكتشف في مراحل
مبكره ما بين الامس
واليوم يعني تغير الكثير يعني السرطان
مرتبط باذهاننا وكلمه سرطان وقعها صعب الى
الان على اذاننا ولكن يعني احنا اللي عم
بنشوفه من دراساتنا ومن استطلاعات الراي
من التماس مباشر مع المجتمع من لقاء
السيدات
بانه قلت كثير الوصمه المتعلقه بالمرض كان
اقل من 60% من اللي بوصلهم يروحوا يا
ياخذوا الخدمه مع انها مجانيه ولكن الان
لا احن عم بنشوف السيدات عم يطلبوا هذا
الشيء وعم يستنوا العياد المتنقله انها
توصل
لمنطقتهم زادت معدلات الكشف المبكر هلا عم
نحكي اكثر من 60% من الحالات عم تكتشف في
المراحل المبكره ولكن هدفنا انه تكون
غالبيه الحالات او كل الحالات مراحل مبكره
ليكون بامكاننا باذن الله يعني السيطره
على المرض والشفاء وضمان يعني انها السيده
تكمل وتتابع حياتها احنا رسالتنا موجهه
للجم رسالتنا موجهه لكل المجتمع على مدار
العام وتحديدا في شهر تشرين الاول اللي هو
الشهر العالمي للتوعيه بسرطان الثدي بدعو
الجميع لدعم الكشف المبكر احنا دائما بحكي
الكشف المبكر ينقذ الحياه والصحه للجميع
وبالجميع فلذلك هي مسؤوليه الجميع كما هي
حق
[تصفيق]
للجميع
ه